and here are the results wow it's twice
as fast empty macbook air versus 14-inch
macbook pro so many of you guys asked us
to do this comparison so here we go we
have spec these two are recommended
configurations and the crazy thing is
that there is only a difference of 150
bucks if you pick up the refurbished
model on amazon which you can return for
90 days and you can get the 14 inch
right now instead of waiting close to a
month so in this video not only are we
going to compare the design the size and
weight the displays speakers we're also
going to do real world productivity
tasks to see how much faster is the
14-inch really and is it worth the extra
cash either 150 bucks in this case or
maybe 200 or 250 if you buy this where
it's constantly on sale and on top of
that we are gonna do a battery life
comparison both of these are at a
hundred percent and a lot of people say
the 14 inch doesn't have great battery
life so we will see how it compares in
real world as we're shooting this video
and running these tests now a lot of
people want to buy the air because of
its portability and when you look at
them online they might not seem like
they're that different but holding them
in the hand you could see that the 14
inch is a little bit taller it's
slightly wider as well and the craziest
part is the difference in thickness and
how light the air is it is dramatic in
the real world now for that extra weight
in size you get more ports on the left
side we have thunderbolt 4 ports on the
14 inch which means you can hook up
additional displays instead of one and
we have our headphone jack and on the
right side you get a full size hdmi 2.0
port another thunderbolt 4 port and an
sd card reader which is very convenient
for creators and of course the 14 inch
has dual fans built in whereas the m2
air is completely fanless now you can
really see the thickness difference when
you have them next to each other look
how much thicker the whole main portion
of the 14 inch is and when i'm resting
my wrists on here you feel this edge a
lot more so than the ultra thin m2
macbook air as far as the keyboards they
are very similar but the macbook air
actually feels better to me because it
has a little bit more feedback and as
far as the track pads both are excellent
the 14 inches slightly larger but
doesn't make a difference in the real
world what will make a difference is the
speakers the m2 ear has no more speaker
grille holes it's hidden inside and
fires up against the screen it does have
two additional speakers that are for the
low end this year compared to a six
speaker system on the 14-inch and i'm
very excited to hear the difference
let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
and there is no contest at all the 14
inch is louder has way deeper bass it
just sounds better in every single way
we were hoping the m2 air would sound
better than it does but with it being so
thin i guess this is the best they could
do so if you care about speakers
definitely the 14-inch this is the
webcam and microphone quality from the
m2 macbook air which was just updated to
a 1080p camera sensor and this is the 14
inch macbook pro i'm really curious how
does this 1080p camera stack up to the
m2 macbook airs and what about the
microphones you guys go ahead and let me
know down in the comment section below
as far as displays it's interesting the
apple labels both 14 inches but the pro
is actually larger as you guys could see
and it has a higher resolution 254 ppi
compared to 227 but when it comes down
to normal use you can't really tell a
difference and the same thing goes for
brightness and for contrast under
regular lighting where the difference
really comes in is for hdr when we're
watching this video the contrast looks
better on the 14 inches mini led display
which has a ton of little zones and leds
and the brightness really pops with that
the colors pop as well it's just a much
better viewing experience and on top of
that if you're somebody that wants to
edit hdr videos or photos you definitely
need the 14 inch now yes you can get
blooming under certain situations with
the mini led on the 14 inch but for the
most part it's a non-issue and it's
better than having a fully gray screen
as far as the bars and the blacks like
you get with lcd displays which is
what's in the m2 macbook air now the
other difference is pro motion the 14
inch has 120 hertz refresh rate which
makes everything super smooth just like
on the new pro iphones compared to being
stuck at 60hz and that can also save you
battery life because it can drop down to
low refresh rates when you're not going
to notice it and now let's get into
performance and see how much of a
difference is there really both of these
are a core models the 14 inch is bend
but the difference is the air has four
performance cores and four efficiency
compared to six performance cores and
two efficiency on the 14 inch the m1 pro
processor also runs at a lower frequency
than the new m2 and now let's go ahead
and do a quick run of geekbench 5 to see
what differences we get remember both
these are equipped with 16 gigs of ram
we're almost done with this test and one
interesting thing is that the fans are
still off on the 14 inch a lot of times
for lower loads or even higher ones that
are a little bit more bursty this is
still technically a machine that's
almost fanless because they're off all
right we have our results and the m2
beats out the 14 inch by nine percent in
single core it has the fastest in core
of any laptop but in multi-core the 14
inch beats out by 11
so there is very little difference in
terms of this general benchmark that
runs a lot of different tasks but we'll
see what the difference is in real world
productivity as far as web browsing the
m2 air does load up websites and
javascript and different things quite a
bit quicker over 40 percent compared to
the 14 inch so if you're looking for a
web browsing machine mainly the air is
definitely going to be great as far as
the ssds we have the 512 model of the
air so it has two nand chips so as you
guys could see it's working really quick
but with that the 14 inch still smokes
it because it's using pci express 4 ssds
so we have a 60 faster write speed and
an 85 faster read speed so you're
getting much better ssds with a 14 inch
now before we jump into the harder tests
i want to give you guys an update on the
battery life our 14 inch is at 90
percent we've been running tests
transferring files maxing out the screen
and the air is also at 90
they are identical for these kind of
lighter easier tasks but now let's jump
into the tough tests and see how they do
as far as music production with logic
we're testing out the new logic
benchmark you can read about it online
and you would think there would be that
big of a difference based on geekbench
but for this task the 14 inch is a lot
more stable we are getting about 135
tracks before it overloads compared to
about 77
so for music production you definitely
want to go for a 14 inch if you're gonna
be using a lot of effects plug-ins and
different tracks and now let's see what
kind of difference we have when it comes
to coding with xcode we're compiling our
code and shortly after we started the
mac heated up right now it's at 108
degrees celsius it bounced down a bit
and back up there so it may be
modulating its power whereas with the 14
inch we're at 81 celsius right now fans
are off 86 celsius is staying right
around there so it's still a fanless
machine even compiling this code and
that took a minute and 19 seconds for
the m2 air and a minute and 11 seconds
for the 14 inch macbook pro so for
shorter compiles like this there is very
little difference in you get a cheaper
system that is lighter and more portable
so some programs might want to go for
this but if you're going to be doing
compiles they're going to be half hour
long or longer then you'll probably
notice a much bigger difference because
of throttling so we tested two of those
apps that are cpu-based but now let's
really max out the cpus and compare
thermals and throttling i'm going to
start out by using my thermal cam to
take a look and get a baseline looks
like the hottest point of the m2 ear is
the display at 31 32 degrees most of
it's very cool
whereas our 14 inch
you guys can see there are some cooler
portions but in general it is warmer
based on the color and now let's start
our 10 minute throttling test in
cinebench we're going to look at the
performance of the systems how much
throttling we get and with that the
frequencies so starting out the m2 air
is running at 3.2 gigahertz compared to
3 gigahertz on the 14 inch and that is
just because of the updated chip with
higher frequencies interestingly power
usage is very similar both 21 uh 21.6
21.6 over there pretty much identical
amounts of power but the 14 inch has
more performance cores the m2 air is
actually averaging slightly more power
than the 14 inch that is crazy and with
that we're already at 108 degrees
celsius on the air whereas here we're at
81 degrees for the highest core 83 now
and the fans are still off and that is
because the m2 air doesn't even have a
proper heatsink there's an empty space
where one could go whereas the 14
14-inch those heat pipes are sucking the
heat away from the cpu and into the fin
section so it has all that thermal
headroom and right now the fans just
kicked on on the 14-inch
it literally took over two minutes of a
hundred percent cpu load in order to get
it hot enough to do that and it was at
about 90 degrees we're at 92 now uh so
apple is not letting the system get as
hot as it does with the m2 air and after
three minutes the m2 air is now using
about 15 watts compared to over 21
before so now it's slowing down we're
running out 2.8 gigahertz almost 2.9
whereas a 14 inch is running steady and
actually using more power now than it
did before once the fans kicked up it's
been five minutes and the 14 inch is
super consistent and as far as the fans
even right there i can't even hear them
it is basically a silent machine and
it's interesting how even the efficiency
cores in the m2 era are over 100 degrees
compared to here where they're in their
80s and the performance cores are in the
90s and that's probably because the m2
has much more powerful efficiency cores
they're about 23
faster and they're being put to use
we're almost done now let's take another
thermal reading our m2 is running at 48
degrees celsius a lot of heat there and
it doesn't spread that much to the sides
whereas the 14 inch we're at 44 45
and you actually see the exhaust right
there blowing hot air up on the screen
and then the sides and bottom stay
cooler and as far as the power
we were starting we started over 21
watts now we're down to 13 and a half on
the m2 so it has throttled quite a lot
and i'm really surprised at the 14-inch
it stays right around 3000 rpms which
aren't even half way the temp stays
stable and the power usage that's
actually higher than at the start and so
it's silent and very consistent even
with 100 load so after all that
throttling what are the results well our
14-inch got
and eleven points and the m2 air got
eight thousand and three points that is
a difference of seventeen percent
much less than i expected after seeing
how much that wattage dropped
previously i think it was like 11
difference for a short burst bursty
tasks so this is definitely not bad now
of course if it was longer than 10
minutes it would slow down even more but
i'm still pretty impressed now if you
guys haven't seen our video on the low
power mode for the m2 air testing out
those efficiency cores you guys have to
check it out after this video you'll be
really impressed so we tested out the
cpu only tasks now let's switch to
graphics the m2 air has an a core bend
gpu that's our preference we did a 8 10
comparison and here we have the 14 core
bin out of 16. we have our results and
it's a pretty big difference the 14 inch
is scoring higher than when we tested it
before and at this point we have 47
uh more score
even though we have about 75 more cores
for this 14 core compared to eight but
we'll see what kind of a difference we
get with real world applications and now
let's push the graphics a little bit
harder and for longer with 3d marks
wildlife extreme stress test this is
going to push it for 20 minutes it's
gonna give us scores
how consistent it is and what kind of
throttling we see if you are doing a
longer load now right out of the gate
our 14-inch is using almost 20 watts of
graphics power compared to about 10
watts for the m2 ear that's twice as
much power usage i'm going to be
interested in the battery life here in a
little bit we are going to let this run
and get back to you guys after almost 20
minutes we are almost done here and
what's very interesting is that they're
both running at very similar
temperatures now the empty air throttled
from about 10 watts down to about 6.8
and staying consistent uh whereas the 14
inch it is running at full power but it
did spin up its fans to about 4 000 rpms
just over half here so they're both
running the same temperatures uh just
we're getting a big difference in
performance and here are the results
this is interesting we have a stability
of 99.5 on the 14 inch that is
incredible consistent performance
compared to 80
on the m2 air meaning
it throttled down and lost performance
as far as frame rates now you guys see
right over here at the start
it did pretty consistently about about
five minutes it just dived down and
throttled a lot and if we scroll over
and look at the last loop loop 20 was
actually the lowest score meaning if you
were playing longer uh or where you're
testing longer
it probably could go down even lower and
realistically if you're playing games
who's going to be gaming for just only
20 minutes now if you're loading up the
gpu very heavily for other tasks that
aren't gaming you're going to see a
similar result so at the start the 14
inch was over 60 percent faster higher
frame rate compared to up to air but
after the 20 minute run it literally was
a hundred percent faster twice the frame
rate so that is a massive difference for
only a little bit more money and now for
those of you guys that want to do some
3d modeling and rendering i have blender
opened up the one that can use the
graphics to do rendering with cycles so
let's go ahead and test out this classic
uh classroom scene all right we are
finished our 14 inch took three minutes
and 38 seconds whereas the m2 took five
minutes and two seconds
nowhere near as big of a difference as
we saw in 3d mark and that is because
this uses a lot less wattage less power
to do this it doesn't heat up as much
doesn't throttle so that difference was
28
the m2 is 28 slower whereas before it
was looking like it was 60 slower 100
slower some blender not a massive
difference and now let's get into some
photo editing i have photoshop opened up
right here with nine different images
we're gonna do an hdr test and let's see
how long it takes with a mix of cpu and
graphics usage wow that was extremely
close
it took 20 seconds for the 14 inch and
22 seconds for
the m2 now the m2 with 16 gigs of ram is
very fast at photo editing so that might
not even be worth upgrading to 14 inch
for you guys but now let's go ahead and
open up lightroom classic and we might
see a bigger difference there as far as
regular editing there is really no
difference they're both extremely snappy
so if you're doing adjustments brushes
it's hard to tell a difference now we're
gonna go ahead and export these 50
edited raw images it's not a lot a lot
of people do way way more than that but
let's see what kind of a difference we
get once again both of these systems are
very fast the
m2 macbook air took one minute and 16
seconds whereas the 14 inch took 56
seconds so the m2 is about 26
slower uh but if you're not doing a ton
of images you're not doing a thousand
1500 for weddings the m2 can do a great
job as long as you don't need hdr and
now for you video editors out there we
have final cut open and we have our
standard 4k test we have some color
corrections applied some luts just your
standard amount of uh effects that
regular people would use and both are
playing them back perfectly fine the
these chips have great encoding engines
and decoding uh as far as the gpu usage
we have 65
on the 14 inch and 71 on the m2 air
that means that it's not that big of a
difference of power required and you
don't have that much more overhead left
over on the 14 inch after running this
that's kind of surprising to me now
let's go ahead and export both of these
five minute projects all right guys this
is interesting we're 85 on the m2 and 76
77
on the 14 inch m1 pro so the encoders
are updated and they are faster
for this m2 processor on the air that
took two minutes in 19 seconds for the
m2 air and 2 minutes and 36 seconds for
the 14 inch now obviously it's not a
huge difference it'll be a slightly
bigger if you're rendering longer
projects but the m2 does encode faster
for your standard compressed footage but
now let's take a look at something a
little bit more difficult this is going
to be pro res raw 4k both these are
playing back perfectly fine and it's
interesting that
the 14 inch actually requires more cpu
and gpu power or a 22 cpu 71 gpu
compared to them to air which is about
13 cpu and about 72 now 71 is changing a
little bit for the graphics uh it's a
weaker system but it requires less of
that probably because apple did add
prores encoders and decoders to system
and it might be a newer version than the
one in the 14 inch so now let's go ahead
and export this five minute project to
pro res with different color gradings
applied and wow look at that the 14 inch
is flying right now we're looking at 31
compared to 19 and that is because our
limitation here is the graphics the
faster the faster the graphics can go
the faster the prores encoders can
encode and in this case both of the
graphics are being maxed out the cpu
we're using more of on the 14 inch
because it can keep up with the graphics
and this export is going quite a bit
faster we have a minute and 51 seconds
for the m2 air and a minute and 7
seconds for the 14 inch it's not twice
as fast but it's close to that so once
you start getting into some tougher
things that will use the cpu and the gpu
and they're not limited we see a bigger
difference and now let's do something
that is much harder this is some 4.5 k
red raw footage that maxes out the gpu
it also uses cpu
and as we take a look neither of these
can play back perfectly at full
resolution they're both skipping frames
it's a lot of graphics power that's
required but of course in final cut we
can go and switch over to the better
performance mode
and that's going to give us it's going
to optimize for playback
and now
it looks like both of them are playing
it back
perfectly smoothly
and it's interesting that the 14 inch is
actually using more graphics power to
play it back then the
uh the m2 air very very interesting now
i do have some film grain applied and
some color corrections and if you're
editing on such a small screen you can
use that better playback mode and it's
going to work well but if you connect to
an external display well that's where it
look way too bad if you're going to
judge focus on things like that and what
about canon raw i have a project from
the c200 here playing it back in normal
mode you guys see
the 14 inches much smoother it's
probably not perfect but it's editable
where this you guys see a ton of
choppiness here this is not workable
unless you go into uh the better
playback mode and now i'm gonna export
this one minute short project that's
going to hammer the cpu and the graphics
right away we hit 180 degrees
celsius on the 14 inch here we're at 92
the fans kicked up all right our m2 ear
took two minutes and eight seconds
compared to one minute and 24 seconds
for the 14 inch so it's not twice as
fast but it's getting close to that so
you guys see when stuff gets tarter the
difference becomes greater and i
actually did the 8k canon raw test which
people said was overkill but wanted to
test out throttling and it took 11
minutes and 21 seconds for the 14 inch
and 21 minutes and 59 seconds for the m2
air so literally it's twice as slow it
takes twice as long
once you start doing something that's
much harder so there you guys go we did
the video editing and now let's take a
look at
battery life
with the 14-inch
we have six percent remaining we started
with 100 we shoot these for hours and
hours and we're hitting them with these
different tests uh but the m2 macbook
air looks like he's more
it has 22
remaining giving us roughly 20
better battery life somewhere like that
now some of these tests they both ran at
the same time
and it also throttled use less power but
some of them the 14 inch was able to do
much quicker and then just sat there and
waited while the
the m2 air was still working so overall
you could definitely expect better
battery life with the m2 air and then of
course you can hook it up to a power
bank and you don't need as much power to
be able to charge it because it uses
less power so there you guys go
which one of these is worth it if you do
care about productivity and performance
and you are going to upgrade your ssd
and your ram
is it worth spending more to get the 14
inch uh it's not that much more
sometimes only 150 bucks or 200 bucks
brand new on sale
well personally i say if you care about
things like photo editing uh video
editing
uh maybe not coding we didn't see much
of a difference there blender especially
and especially gaming the 14 inch
definitely comes out ahead especially if
you're gonna do extended tests whereas
if you do some of those tasks but you're
a hobbyist level
and you care about having a system
that's small and lightweight great
battery i think the m2 macbook air is
still very capable you guys saw those
tests
especially if you care about having a
portable package and you want to save a
little bit of money it will still do a
surprisingly good job in some of these
tasks let us know your thoughts in the
comment section down below please hit
that subscribe button if you guys enjoy
these videos check out one of those
right over there that's been max with
max tech and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]